it's a beastly tournament warzone Kings
get ready nuts crazy crazy stuff
happening soon war zone raided 1 minute
53 gladiators with the hefty average
rating for this type of tournament 18:56
time handicap here we go let's roll
Lancaster oh this guy was he it was this
the was this the winner of the last
tournament let's go right in for this
we're playing um are we playing here if
I push that pond suit too soon what
would have happened let's just chop here
and then be extra cautious I guess I'd
be extra cautious planned this like it's
a long game why did I do that move but I
drop a piece like that hit a rook hit
the knight ok this is a problem come on
King be a defender you know you want to
defend ok this is a problem
come over here is it gonna be safe this
is not a good start to turn them and if
you can't get the first win you have to
get the first win
stop that pond from rolling please oh
he's gonna be rolling or is he yes he is
scariness scariness Oh
pawn push is very good ah that's a very
good move oh they're gonna take my rook
I know I don't have anything oh I'm a
dead man there's no way you could win
this is there this is sad this is a sad
day how much time is left can I somehow
get this come on Bishop help Oh be a
contributor get this Knight out of here
somehow clock situation is actually not
so bad
Oh Forks and everything watch out for
the forks clock situation is not bad
it's not bad at all pre moves time
burners where the time burners the time
burn once again time is my best friend
that's all we have that's all I have
don't look at any good play just look at
the clock if you're looking at the
pieces you're looking in the wrong spots
do not look at any squares do not look
at any pieces just look at the clock
because that's all I have just cross
your fingers and hope just hope seconds
go away because I'm not gonna be winning
games objectively forget about it it's
just not happening
that was a nice shot did you see that I
saw that I felt that too
I felt that pun coming down landing a
for grabbing right up promoting to a
queen all that stuff was no fun that was
no fun for me a lot of fun for my
opponent oh oh that's a free pond is it
I'm gonna take the free pond take the
take the darker Bishop there's gonna be
trickiness right here I think trickiness
no I take with the check now exploit the
pin I would have taken the queen with
check if it had moved I keep on push I
could take like this because there's a
pin or ruski right here at c-file pin
ruski ah let's take here and I'm gonna
have to run a little bit with my rook
run defend a little bit just a little
bit just a hair oh why can't it be easy
let's do this Queen here get that pawn I
just want to get that pun pressure here
I have this covered over here right are
they gonna take they're gonna take okay
let's come back here to defend they
don't have any time no no no no no no no
no no over here they're gonna throw in a
check or are they let's take here and
come here anyhow oh they're gonna take
this run King time burners time burners
where are you okay they're being sneaky
no they're down on time they're being
sneaky and they're down in time okay 25
that's all I have I'm
trying to tell you I'm not joking around
just look at the clock okay I feel like
bringing that look this little thing
over here just so you can look at it
just throw it off you name the side King
side or queen side where do you want
this thing castle
okay look right here that can't be bad
can it this night oh they're trying to
fishing Paul me Oh watch oh I better not
get fishing pulled okay let's get rid of
that light-square bishop he's bad news
he's bad news oh man oh man oh I didn't
move I'm glad I didn't move I'm gonna
end up in a fork it's okay though
here comes a fork run over here King
just take that rook it's gonna be a lot
better for me I think Queens are off
again here we go no check a ruski let's
block here the rook is gonna give a
check let's do this run back over here
you know it's safe over here don't you
oh I didn't want to give up my darks for
a bishop like that what's this guy doing
what's my light-square bishop doing oh
you got to come over here that's all I
have to push my pond no no no no no I
need to keep the Queens on the board oh
maybe I don't
oh I got the Queen I got the Queen don't
call me out don't come Oh sneaky this at
every corner sneakiness at every corner
is this me it's happening soon I think
Maitland no it's not no it's not not yet
I got a rock I got a rock I got a rope
give a check hope for the best pins pins
pins mates coming up 1 2 3 1 2 I lied
it's for something close something close
19 that's that's Wolf Man up top Wolf
Man
that's all I ever have is a I could only
ever clock burn wolf
okay open Sicilian or otherwise
okay let's regroup here you could do it
you could win a game on toss a clock
kick you could win the game without the
clock can you launch the fishing Paul
everything will be okay
or will it the fishing pole is here this
is the pole and here's the bait here's
the bait
he can't be taken right now but
light-square weaknesses of g3
light-square weaknesses light-square
weaknesses let's go take here if the
pond pushes it could be bad news real
soon oh the knight could play here maybe
Mike could play here maybe I gotta break
that pin and I need to get more
development in Bishop to e7 and g5 let's
go g5 might be good or no let's go with
h4 first okay this is good this Knight
is boxed out let's give a check the King
is running for the hills where is he
come on push pawn push again pirate push
this is a giant Thor and watch out for
the thorns watch out for the mega ones
this is a making one thread I didn't
realize until I played here but it is
it's a mating one that's a quick kill it
is I got it I finally won one I finally
won one game I got 20 who's this this
guy again
this is the guy that should've give me a
beating and a half from the first game
oh no he's not gonna let the clock run
out this time he's like I know what his
plan is his plan is to just burn a clock
I am NOT gonna allow that this time
that's what he's saying
I could feel it that's the sense I'm
getting right here he's just saying you
know what oh I shouldn't have done that
I shouldn't have done that I shouldn't
have done that
I should have I'm in pins and everything
I'm it pins again oh it's just target
practice for this guy I'm just target
practice what did I do to deserve this
let's get out of the pan before it's too
late can i weasel around
I can't weasel around let's get out of
the pin Knight here next is this somehow
working no no no no
don't you dare don't you dare don't you
dare don't you dare what else do I have
if I don't have that here I guess this
working
oh let's block like that I guess and
then here oh no it's not working again
sneaking this oh I just dropped
everything I just dropped everything man
pins everywhere I'm cutting across fire
how many pieces can you lose you can
lose the whole count ah this is so
brutal this is so brutal every piece is
dead should I just resign I should
probably just resign they're not gonna
lose this one are they no they're not
because that is mate oh man back to
tournament land thirty twenty twenty he
had enough of my antics he said you know
enough is enough
I know your sneakiness okay there's
still time though there's still a lot of
time to come back I need a clutch win
and who do I have right here clutch I'm
playing against clutch just in time okay
let's go let's roll kill that Bishop and
then pounce on the dark squares I don't
really want to allow this pawn to
recapture and have them build a center
though let's try this
oh man okay Knight g4 95 okay let's try
it anyhow in a castle Bishop to b7 and
oh okay let's do this
I'm on the bishop I want to get Bishop
to b7 in and what else what - c8 oh I
should just take in the bishop oh ok if
the knight moves I take on c3 what's
check
ok let's pile up on this we got here now
we got d6
and we have no time for my opponent just
take this bishop and it's crash through
here I'd liked okay look oh I'm on this
enough I have more defenders on this
it's dropping a piece and then oh that's
me that's me that's me that's me
dr. term at 28 still a close race 5
points separating the first 7 right here
oh man ok 18 minutes in change 18
minutes and change let's do this efore
efore okay let's build this Center we
need to pawn push okay they're gonna
want a small pond center it might be
happening it might be happening keep
that night away kick them away dark
square weaknesses and then let's do what
next let's shut that Bishop down this
pawn triangle does just that
and now I want to get to this no I don't
know where I'm going with that I don't
know I want to get here can I get that
I'm floundering with my my pieces right
here is this working not even sure what
that night woof is tilting what does
that not even doing there he's not in a
good position is he okay now I want to
hop here and then play here in case the
night goes there I don't want the night
to get to f4 I want to maintain my
Knights position my LightSquared Bishop
needs to do something else
you get my pieces working here this is a
good diagonal let's come over here clean
over maybe King in the corner and then
b4 that's more to the point I could give
a check should probably throw that one
in there or not okay that's a good move
before coming up let's keep that night
around let's keep them around how much
time this guy is playing quick it's my
worst fear right there okay I have
enough defense on this I could support
it next like that this bishop can't do
anything I'm looking for just a pawn
push next pawn push if I take okay then
this could be taken pawn push again
support this before I think I want to
run with b4 really soon open up the B
file and I'm not gonna take just yet I
want to prep it a little bit more I
don't know why I need to do that King
move let's just get all my pieces
working although this pawn is following
I want to smash through real soon and
they're out of that right thing Bishop
I'll pawn up a few times a few times
here oh I had a pawn push a bunch of
times didn't I I had that pawn push
earlier and it would have been a fork
Queen takes pawn I get they I get the
Amb file I want to keep the Queens on
the board maybe although Queen takes and
then I'm gonna fork they're down on time
go figure
go figure that's it they're not getting
mated they're just losing on time double
those points look for c5 and and then
what what is the play and after that who
knows okay get your pieces out watch out
for the sneaky stuff sneaky stuff sneaky
stuff right around the corner stinky
stuff Queen right here is a loser
can't do that that wouldn't be a good
idea still can't be taken I could take
there I kept this pawn Oh where's the
knight gonna go oh oh this could be big
trouble really fast really really fast
uh-oh Oh be careful
break the pin pawn push I don't know
just queenside castle
nor this I'm on that bishop twice I'm
gonna go with the Queen here here right
here if Bishop takes Knight I just swing
over here this is leading to mate
unavoidable Queen takes pawn is the only
just take here and then mate coming up
that's the one that can't be prevented
okay back to tyrant that was kind of
quick 65-63 56 54 54 putts 12 double
those points E for 15 minutes were
halfway there I should have went with
the fantasy variation I don't know if
Queen c7 is a good idea prepping it pond
push of castles okay
avoid the knight exchange I have a space
advantage if a played there I was still
gonna go here I want to get rid of the
dark square Bishop not take the knight
get rid of this guy and give a check
Knight here next with check and then get
my other night here let's see what it
gets done though I want my queen to get
here I want to keep my knight around and
let's take this on on the rook and then
crash through I'm the f5 square this is
a this is a tough bind a very very
difficult bind right here this is matin
one two three I was there something
quicker one two right here works any
move can gets to go there back to
tournament back to tournament 1781 70 70
63 okay
Shafer 84 c5 let's get a center built in
here can we get a center built in here
okay I should have just pushed I'm
looking to just push that oh they're
going to reverse oh what's happening
what's happening here silly chess
running in Reverse is white okay let's
get castled my LightSquared bishop wants
to be where right here
pawn push next c4 can be played maybe
take stakes and then I have made if the
knight moves is the makin a move it's
moving
f2 that was a quick kill 88 88 88
163 land castor the guy who should have
beaten me the first game and then beat
me the second time we played let's try
this it's a little different
why not o tempo I'm the co I just got
the bishop I have here check next are
they gonna resign I'm not a queen I was
in my lip all right no not a mouse lift
that was just I was just a blender
wasn't it I'm on the Queen they might
miss it
I missed initially maybe they'd miss it
too or not
okay goes to b6 I Castle just open up
this position let's stay here I want to
keep pressure on this pawn so the bishop
has trouble getting active bishop here
Knight move here out a knight you move
here looks good okay I didn't want to
take here because of rook stuff so let's
not do that if they cast like it maybe
capture here let's capture here and then
follow up with Knight to g5 if allowed
just kind of giving that piece back but
now the Kings side has been shattered I
want to remove this Knight and then look
for matin
okay Bishop here is also trained on this
square I could take with a check I'm
gonna go with that oh okay I have sneaky
stuff here Bishop check and I'm on the
Queen I might have to do a pawn push
here okay this is with check and now my
bishop what can I do I'm not even sure
what it is even doing if I move it
there's nothing no good discoveries I
don't think right there let's just do
this I guess time time time time time no
quick wins here just go quickly go
quickly anything anything anything
anything just keep moving just keep
moving this pawn is falling straight a
rug I have this guarded here
all right anything anything anything
anything back determine 108 I have a
lead 108 99 98 81 okay 11 and change
ming-ming gorilla in gorilla okay
anyhow this okay let's avoid that okay
let's get a night out here let's do what
86
okay well now there's that the bishops
gonna be playing there so I got a block
that not so easy here that's so easy is
it Bishop to e7 night here if this pawn
is ready to push I'm okay with doubled
pawns these actually are quite good
doubled pawns of course there's a 3-2 to
majority now in favor of white but I'm
not so sure that could be put to good
use I could get rid of the darks for a
bishop and maybe pivot my piece is about
on that square so let's get real cure
Bishop here in Knights e7 now I should
play Bishop here first let me get rid of
that dark square Bishop all right well I
guess we're gonna have this I want to
get my bishop on d4 dark squares open
wide open here open wide open and then
pawn push this is this is a brutal right
here rook up and over
oh oh look up and then over I want my
rope right here if allowed I want a
right there they're out of pins but my
rook is getting very active very active
Oh bishops gonna take their isn't it I
can come back though that's pretty scary
I'm gonna let that Knight sit there as
scary as it is oh it's even scarier what
Bishop takes pawn would have been killer
don't have any time big surprise big
surprise if they don't have any time
making one threat Queen right here isn't
making one threat they're down on time
back to terminate one 1699 90 99 minutes
and change remaining
double those points efore well let's go
here let's go and what are we gonna have
okay let's take here oh okay let's take
let's do Knight to f3 Bishop to d3 and
the Queen was close to being trapped
right here just Castle you know you just
want a Castle kingside
King side just Castle just Castle oh not
castling what does that King would even
doing it's not needed
there's pond can be taken maybe now
without some scary stuff happening
though right
alright let's dance a little bit just a
little bit oh she's gone back and forth
I'm gonna take I want to get this file
right here I'm gonna kick that night
away bishop it's pin Bishop takes I'm on
the Queen I want to take that nutty and
then give a check that Knights having
some trouble here it's pawn push I want
to get to this square i g g5 my queen
let's make this happen
g5 where is it out okay with check and
now this is it has to be good the rook
is dead and the Queen doesn't have very
many squares this is check where's the
mate rook up and over where does that
mean there's no good sir there's no good
moves I don't think for uh let's do this
if Queen here I play rook f4 I think I'm
controlling everything
rook f4 and then there's something on f7
happening real soon real soon
also just rook here this is leading to
mate actually this is a main threat rook
to this square this is better than the
rook f4 move on the Queen leading to a
million-two this is one and then this is
to back to term at 148 136 lancaster the
winner of the last term is right up
there and 1:30 as well right there
whatever you do do not get in forth
avoid forth at all costs okay well it's
castle we're not getting sniffing out
fishing stuff it's being snifter right
out oh I should have moved my a pond
before I pushed let's do it now capture
like this and okay let's push this night
around a little bit night here Bishop
here actually I'll take first I don't my
queen I don't I wouldn't want my queen
to be displaced and I have this square
covered I need to watch over that
actually upon push I think soon it's
gonna be good oh oh oh oh oh sneaking
this everywhere huh I gotta come back if
I took there was a pen I would have been
in some trouble oh man how much time how
much time notice how my thoughts went
right to the clock right there did you
notice that how obvious is that as soon
as I know I'm losing right what's the
clock situation
what's the clock I look right at that
clock that's all I have the clock my
king needs to hide on e7 I think come on
King
come over here where it's safe nice and
cozy over here don't get rid of my light
square bishop okay I'm okay what a queen
trade let's do this let's do this let's
avoid the rook here is good oh oh I
gotta be sneaky
oh look here is good too I gotta avoid I
need to I need time burners this is the
last time burner I have the last time
burner he's gonna grab this guy I could
get this one with check uh-oh time
burners happening now uh-oh
could kill this pawn come back here pins
pins pins everywhere discoveries beware
the discoveries time burners time
burners no no no no no no no time
burners come over here they're down on
time 170 I'm in second five minutes
remaining 170 168
Edie Edie BOGO let's go for 5500 that
night's gonna kill me isn't it okay I
need to get rid of that night I think
and then put a question to this [ __ ] up
recapture here are they gonna take they
are gonna take I'm gonna take here and
okay is there gonna be a problem they're
gonna be a prop is there gonna be a
problem okay good now the B file is
closed I want to break through room that
F pond oh the night's gonna be sitting
pretty right there he could be kicked
away though
f7 this night needs to go undermine the
night we wrote to have five if the
rookies challenge I want my night on
that five I should probably look to Rima
new Rima no for a pretty position it
Rima new for the night my night wants to
get to have six its licking his chops on
f6 where does he want to go right here I
guess I need to get rid of this night I
think he's too strong clean trade no no
no no no no no no okay let's do this
and I could give check right here and
then get my rook on the seventh and then
my other rook over here is that working
this is working though a tactic tricky
tactics this is leading to Maine check
check and then for a second I thought
the Queen was actually guarding my Ripa
but it's not regarding G one is to the
h-11 9188 three minutes in change come
on I could get maybe two more in one
more one more definitely and I'm needing
to win for sure definitely needing to
win this the points have been doubled is
this guy gonna move or is he gonna be
just a time burner I might be okay with
a time burner look at the clock look at
the clock
three minutes so do the calculations
there'll be two minutes two minutes and
25 seconds remaining about and I'll have
a chance for one more game right and
look at the clock up here
look at the clock up here because before
it's happy it's happened before
where my clock was not moving and then
all of a sudden I ended up losing so
let's go here thirteen twelve eleven
this is maybe exactly what I needed
exactly because the points have been
doubled what are the standings - 10 that
guys - 10 - 10 this game is gonna finish
come on come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on come on don't
check the server no don't check the
server don't there checking the server
this is another 9 seconds these are
precious seconds ah oh these are
precious seconds don't check the server
back to tournament 208 uh I need to win
and that guy needs to not win we're not
finished
edie again are we gonna have that same
line let's try this is it any different
I'm gonna make it different I'll go from
Bishop I saved myself a move I saved
myself a move by Oh pins pins pins pins
pins pins this is a pin I'm winning the
knight the bishop movement is not good
because there's no b5 now they might
resign are they gonna resign they're not
gonna resign I'm getting everything
though I'm getting a full rook - here
yeah at this pawn push if the rook takes
Queen side castle uh I don't even know
what that's doing I'm giving the piece
back where's the mate where's the mate
where's the mate where's the maid one
minute thirteen I'm not gonna get two
games in I have to look for just one umm
my bishop
Oh my bishop my bishop right here we
have I have to watch out for me here no
I don't is that not gonna move they
resigned they retired they resigned two
- two - two - what - twenty-eight 556 I
have a lead
did that guy lose or is he just ready to
win did that guy loser is he just ready
- is he just ready to win he might be
just ready to win can I get another game
in 46 45 seconds 45 45 45 fishing poles
my only
that's my only chance my only chance my
only chance my only chance it might be
happening you know you just want a
castle please that's my only hope it's
my only hope it's my only hope
twenty-nine seconds remaining just take
the knight take the knight it's okay ah
they didn't take the knight 22 seconds I
got to make something happen and it's
not happening for 17 seconds 17 seconds
quick quick quick quick quick
oh I had the floor guy to fork guy to
fork bishop check if the pond moves I
got the Queen I could take here making -
maybe where's the Queen gotta go
oh oh just take just take just take what
I get its second oh he must have just
won ah so close second oh man if you had
20 games in good games craziness once
again